with her quick wit girl-next-door vibe
and a last name that screams Hollywood
legacy big screen glory seemed a
certainty for Bridget Fonda and from the
late 80s into the 90s Fonda's career was
the very definition of glorious then she
disappeared since 2002 Fonda hasn't
appeared in a single film or TV show if
you're among the many fans wondering
where she went
don't worry we dug up a few answers for
you too much too soon
vonda's family named all but demanded a
big screen breakthrough and Fonda
definitely made the most of her time in
the spotlight between 1987 and 1998 she
consistently made three to four films a
year more than 30 and all with that sort
of workload it's easy to imagine that
Fonda simply burned out and who could
blame her Fonda was basically working
nonstop for 11 straight years we can
only imagine the effect it had on her
Viet girl problem with roles in the hit
thriller single white female and the
acclaimed Cameron Crowe drama D singles
plus cameos in films like 1992 s army of
Darkness it looked like there was no
genre she couldn't handle and she could
draw a solid box office numbers two
single white female alone made nearly 50
million dollars upon release with that
sort of success Fonda's it girl status
was unavoidable while Fonda continued to
work steadily in the years that followed
her momentum slowed during the late 90s
and as many other stars can attest once
your career cools off it's hard to heat
it up again
monkey bone the crowded schedule Fonda
maintained at her peak may actually help
explain some of her more questionable
career choices
none of which proved quite as
questionable as 2001's monkey bone
pitched as a madcap action animation
comedy mashup it probably sounded like a
risk worth taking for Fonda
unfortunately it proved to be three
things that Hollywood just won't
tolerate expensive difficult to market
and almost unwatchable monkey bone
tanked at the box office and although
she wasn't blamed for its poor
performance it remains one of Fonda's
last few big screen efforts to date TV
didn't pan out television producers
pursued Fonda for years in fact she
actually turned down the lead role on
Ally McBeal in 1999 so she could focus
on making movies it's tough to
second-guess that decision Ally McBeal
ended quiet
after five seasons and didn't exactly
set its lead Calista Flockhart on the
path to film stardom but Fonda's own
television efforts didn't really pan out
either
she took a supporting role in the Chris
Isaak show and appeared in the TV movies
no ordinary baby and Snow Queen bladder
release premiered in December of 2002
and Fonda hasn't appeared in a film or
television project since family shadow
we can't imagine it was an easy decision
for Fonda to walk away from acting after
all when your father is legendary actor
Peter Fonda your grandfather is
legendary actor Henry Fonda and your
aunt is legendary actor Jane Fonda a
career in Hollywood might seem like more
of a birthright than a career choice but
legacies also come with expectations and
when your family has as many heavy
hitters as the Fonda clan those
expectations are essentially tripled
though Brigitte undeniably had a solid
career it was hardly the stuff of legend
and sometimes it's tough to break out of
your family shadow married life the
vagaries of Hollywood aside Fonda had
another personal reason to stop looking
for roles her relationship with composer
Danny Elfman shortly after a 2003 car
crash left Fonda with a fractured
vertebrae the actress announced her
engagement to the former Oingo Boingo
frontman after they married in 2003 she
spent time helping him raise his
children from a previous relationship
and the pair welcomed their own son
Oliver in 2005 Fonda has maintained a
low profile since never too late
who's to say that Bridget Fonda won't
find her way back to the red carpet one
day Hollywood loves a good comeback and
for proof look no further than Bridget's
own father Peter Fonda spent the better
part of the 70s 80s and 90s toiling away
in B movies he didn't break back into
Hollywood's good graces until his
oscar-nominated turn in 1997's hughley's
gold in this new golden age of
television we'd like to thank Bridget's
Road back would be a little easier and a
challenging supporting role on a great
Netflix or Amazon series might be just
the ticket to get her back in front of
cameras thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]